What's your favorite season?
My favorite season is spring.
The weather is cool and sunny.
I like to plant flowers.
Wow, that's really great.
How about you, Arthur?
What's your favorite season?
My favorite season is summer.
I like hot weather because I can go to the beach and sunbathe.
I love having cold drinks on the beach.
That sounds good too.
How about you, Sandra?
What's your favorite season?
My favorite season is autumn.
I love to go hiking.
All the leaves are changing color.
The trees look so beautiful.
How about you, Luke?
What's your favorite season?
My favorite season is winter.
Summer is too hot for me.
I like cold weather and love to go snowboarding.
So winter is best for me.